well Life For Life hello good morning
good afternoon good evening wherever the
hell you are in the world and welcome to
Stargate live Stargate Sunday
gentlemen
no I said say hello gentleman
hello gentlemen
hello gentleman
hello gentlemen right we get to do our
star you Matthew did us a lovely
starting intro for this and we've not
got to use it yet but here we go
[Music]
foreign
welcome to Stargate Sunday where once a
month we talk everything's Stargate
um guys get into the comments tell us
what you want us to talk about hey
Shelly's in the house
um
and Jake's in the house and a couple of
other people so carry them who's very
very excited who is our newest moderator
um so thank you Kerry for being with us
so right this week has been a bit
interesting because I dropped the um
video earlier in the week about
um this plot summary that has been
leaked to me through MGM and the Bad
Robot plus summary
so
guys
first of all what did you roughly think
or should we just start breaking it down
yes or no I hated it I absolutely hated
it
yeah
me too if I could punch the screen and
not break things that's what I would do
I hated it not much do you actually
violently hate it
yeah
I think
I think it's a cop out
the the storyline that decided to go
down I think it's
that
I can kind of get on board with the
switch in actors
because the because Kurt Russell was
O'Neill in the first place so I can kind
of get on board with that but yeah no
just overall no I hate it I don't think
it makes sense more more than anything
like it wouldn't like
the good old
rabbit rather be it still being alive we
would have known about that like he
can't just hide no
Indiana Jones got a nuclear weapon to
the face and he just hidden a fridge and
he survived
and he was fine
and we were all okay with that were we
got around if they got around it with
maybe if they got around it with maybe
the idea that he was in the sarcophagus
when he blew up then he could survive
that way but we saw him out of this
sarcophagus getting destroyed so uh we
saw him melt yeah that makes no sense
from producers from a the movie Maker's
point of view I can completely
understand
where they've pulled this idea from
but we've seen it a million times I said
it in the first video it's very
formulaic they go into a formula here
it's very it reminds me of Independence
Day the second independence day they
just brought back the same villain and
it was 20 years later
yeah like it's just the same thing
they're just doing the same but that
didn't work either that was
crap crap
yeah I'm sure that was a really good
point we didn't get it but I'm sure it
was a really good point
a little bit so my first question for
you guys and guys in the audience and
the um audience in the comments please
tell me the same as well Kurt Russell
over Richard Dean Anderson that's that's
the first thing we've gotta get out of
this
and now I want you to when we're asking
these questions I want you to put
yourself in the mindset of the fan but
also put your mindset of the people
actually making the movie so Amazon
putting up 150 million dollars
to make this film
Matt Kurt Russell or Richard Dean
Anderson as a fan
as a fan I would always pick RDA
because he has played the role for way
longer and the the character was
expanded because of him
but I see I see why they might want to
do Kurt Russell and I'm fine with either
but I would prefer Richard as an
executive though which would you go for
I mean as an executive you probably
would go for Kurt Russell wouldn't you
yeah I think so how about you Harris as
a fan RDA or Kurt Russell oh RDA all day
I I honestly I prefer Kurt Russell at
the end of the day just as a general
actor but for Stargate
RDA all day
yeah but if you're an executive signing
the check RDA he spent 10 15 18 years in
a row Kurt Russell doesn't know the
character anymore Kurt Russell would
have to do a year and a half's worth of
homework just to get back into the
character where RDA can just
we'll hop right back into it all he does
all he needs to do is get in a little
bit of shape RDA is
arguably not just as famous as Kurt
Russell in any way but he's just as many
faces around the globe have seen him he
was a MacGyver for almost a decade prior
to a decade of Stargate decade and a
half of Stargate
he is just
enough but people know him and people
would still go
at least the entire Stargate fan base
would be in seats for that
and if that fan base is their word of
mouth would be just hopefully great from
there if the movie's good of course
yeah
come on guys look at Russell being
Jack again is as Harris just said he's a
completely different character
so he'll be drawing on the experience
that he had when he played it with Jack
O'Neill back in the original movie
but that character has developed a ton
like he's no longer the depressed guy
going on a suicide mission because his
son died he's grown as a person as a
character
so much has happened
are we they are we gonna go are we are
we essentially going to get the movie
O'Neill back or is it gonna it is it
gonna be a play of basically is it going
to be how Michael Shanks did James
Spader in sg1 for the first half of the
Season where he done a James Spader
impression is that what uh Kurt Russell
was essentially going to do with Richard
Dean anston or is it going to be what he
was originally which if he's going to do
the original character I think shit's on
the
um she's on the franchise it slaps
Richard Dean amster in the face who did
it for
this might be your very next question
but you brought it up Matt would James
Spader come back or are we gonna have
Michael Shanks because James Spader yes
he was in Avengers Age of Ultron but ask
ask how many people actually know that
so realistically he's been levied into a
TV star he's not a movie star anymore
either he's a TV star Michael Shanks is
a TV star
who wins that battle there and then that
of course could cause so much more
commotion depending on RDA Kurt Russell
Etc I mean that hasn't been discussed as
far as I know with this booth with this
pitch
and but James made his TV show The
Blacklist has just come been canceled
after 10 years though they really
shouldn't call it being canceled after
10 years they should just go and bloody
hell you've done an amazing well done
um but they're about to be the final
season so
there's that I love James Spader I think
he's great I mean on Thursday and all
the way through just every little
mannerism of whatever they're all trying
you just got out of my things he's good
um
but but yeah I mean
the only way I would not complain
about Richard Dean Anderson or Michael
Shanks really not coming back as if they
don't want to
right which I did say in the honest
Stargate science video
um I think we'll struggle getting
returning Anson to come back I think if
Brad had done this was in charge I think
he could have talked him into it but he
wouldn't do much he'd do a few little
cameos
I think it's more likely if they go a
completely different way Richard Dean
Anderson won't want anything to do with
it in which case bring Kurt Russell back
for the movie kill him off I don't
really mind
um
um I I think it's a I think it would be
I can see why they've done it from an
executive's point of view because it
would be Gators would be like the [__]
sort of thing but also symbolically it's
a nice move into the next movie you know
it's a um it's you know it really is it
like Stargate as you know is done new
franchise we're going you know this way
so I can in this executive I completely
understand why they're doing this or why
they thought of it as a good idea as a
gator I'm like you are [__] mental
Dean Anderson is O'Neal what the hell
are you thinking
the only problem I can see or one of the
big problems I can see is in the script
uh Jack dies
yeah so no matter so if Richard Dean
Hansen plays it that's a nice send-off
for his character but if Kurt Russell
plays it it means we're never going to
see Richard Johnson again
yeah
I think it would have been a really nice
goodbye to Richard Dean Anderson I think
well and if he's gonna die in the film
anyway why why wouldn't RDA come back
and playing how would that be difficult
to get him I guess he'd have to get in
shape and do all these different things
but he's been getting in shape yeah
that's what I was going to say he's been
getting there so what and thinking about
it I guess as an executive from Amazon
they are trying to cut costs in a lot of
ways Kurt Russell's a lot more expensive
than RDA and you do have a solidified
base of people that will know that will
go to that theater no matter what if RDA
is there still
I don't know if it's more cost
proficient or not to get currency the
other thing is if you believe the rumor
about that guy whose name's gonna go
completely on my head and the guy from
Top Gun Maverick recently
um
yeah apparently there's no room is that
he would be he's the movie star isn't he
so RDA would appease us we'd be very
very happy the executives have still got
a movie star to put on the poster
and he's the guy that then will be
taking the franchise forwards in theory
um so maybe that's the best of both
worlds so maybe that's where they're
going
um I don't know if that is part of this
um
thing like I say this pitch was done in
um October or very early in November
apparently
so I heard about this other fella this
is like late December early January
apparently he was approached so this
that could be based on something
completely different that we don't know
about yet gotta remember I only get
snapshots of what's going on at MGM I
don't get the whole picture
so I mean I get a lot more than most
people but I don't get the whole picture
so I I just know that one of these days
I mean I talk about every possibility in
every rumor that comes out and when it
gets announced it's going to be
something completely different I'm going
to be like I'm in here though but anyway
um
so we mentioned bringing back ra really
quickly I mean I think
we're all in agreement
bring a rod it doesn't make sense and
again from an executive point of view
MGM Stargate 10th highest grossing movie
of all time
can you understand them maybe trying to
bring something from that movie back
into the new movie
as a Gateway into a new series
it's too old to bring back the original
character though the whole point of
Stargate was about mythology you could
bring someone else from a different
mythology it doesn't have to be rather's
dead the all the Egyptian gods are dead
yeah it could be other go Awards like
I've always liked the idea that although
like the system Lords have been
destroyed They're All Dead there are
still grow old out there obviously
they're not they didn't they didn't
commit genocide so they couldn't be like
another one rise to power at some point
in the future that's that's a route they
could have gone down
yeah
and it's it's a villain the the
loose Stargate fans know I think that's
the that's the reason why they've done
it the you know the the peripheral fans
or the people that just watch the movie
never really watch the series
um and they know this villain I think
again that's why they've done it and I
think it is so unimaginative
um sorry I'm just gonna have to put that
on that is that is so funny
Shira
pick up a firework in less than an hour
um but I think it's just I I think it's
ladies I think it's stupid and again the
risk they've got is I think with a lot
of these plans
they might appease the peripheral
person but they're gonna piss off Gators
you know what I mean it's like
90 of the people are going to watch this
film and watch the series and it's going
but I mean the hardcore Gators though
the people that actually watch this
Channel people actually come on here and
you know the guys in the subscription at
the moment in the comments at the moment
are gonna be really really annoyed by
this
the only way I think they could do this
is this if he says he's ra and then
later on the Move we find out it's not
him and he's an imposter or something
um is but I mean even that makes sense
but yeah that's still stretching it
it's just crap stupid well
yeah even if it was raw
why would he have followers why would he
have Jafar when
essentially the entire Jafar nation is
now free and they know that they're
false gods and the whole of this system
Lord like hierarchy has been dismantled
why if ra came back would they were they
all of a sudden bowed out they Revolt it
would never happen they were just like
he'd come in they'd be like I'm right
I'm your guard and they'd be like mate
it's been 10 years you've been dead all
your mates are dead like Dragon like
I can't believe this every time is um
bow down to your God
everything that's what I would do every
time for us to go home and make all my
stuff open
says go over there and do this
um right so a movie at all so just
before about an hour before the live I
did a very quick short just saying hey
guys we're going live in an hour well
done for noticing and appearing guys and
I just said you know what do you think
yes or no movie
it's a bit split
heckett says no movie that's going to
screw things up gone fishing it might be
nice as an introduction to the new film
Angela yesh LG McGee yes
um frazetto 100 no just to bring us a
new series don't mess around silver
speed yes so it's pretty 50 50.
what do you guys think do you if you
know what is a movie the best way to
kick-start a new franchise
I like the idea but like like what we've
been talking about are they going to
make it more for the peripheral group of
people are they going to make it for
Starbase just Starbase Stargate fans
because I I think it's pretty pivotal
that they have to at least
appease and more so than just the peas
we need to be satiated as Stargate fans
with whatever project they release first
because that's going to set them up and
they want that base of fans they already
have to be excited to be okay this is
back a little new a little different but
it's back that's what we kind of want
and
are they going to deliver that are they
going to deliver peripheral oh this
would be good for anybody and everybody
and that's that's always good but
how formulaic and how generic can
something be
compared to you know
what we all know and love and have known
to love for a while now
100 what do you think now
is it a good way to kick stuff I like
the idea of a movie
but I just don't know how
they could tell a story that honors the
TV show and the original movie as well
because that's obviously part of the
Canon
um in a way that's
not gonna be
like
something didn't happen like they're
gonna they're gonna ruin it they're
gonna piss on
one part one portion of it like so
whether it's
something that happened in sg1 SGA
whatever
I I honestly think a TV show would be
better because then it can actually
continue what's already happened
but I know at the same time a movie
would bring in a lot more attention
but it's just it's just the logistics
like what how are you going to do it
without pissing someone off do you know
I think the main risk of the movie and
it's why I I genuinely don't want them
to go the movie route I only keep
talking about it because it's what I
keep hearing a lot of people okay a lot
of people in the comments do need to
remember as well that when I talk about
something it's because what I'm being
told it's not my opinion stop attacking
me
what I'm saying people do seem to think
that the whole Bad Robot thing is my
fault is it not Jay
isn't involved secretary
no no no no no
um so no not not me no not compending no
not containing about robot
um but I think the biggest risk of the
movie is if it bombs
if if they do a movie 150 million dollar
movie and it doesn't do very well and
you know the cinema at the moment
it's it's a wild west you know it's like
God knows what's gonna happen if if they
do us a Stargate movie and it even just
breaks even it doesn't have to bomb just
not do well
it kills the franchise dead done yeah
and that's my biggest worry I I know a
TV show done even reasonably well will
do okay and it'll cost 10 hours of
Television will cost half what the movie
will cost
um you know they're looking at 10 hours
of TV would cost 70 to 80 million
dollars a movie will cost at least 150
million dollars
now
so that's my biggest risk uh that's the
thing that keeps me up at night I do
like that guy foreign
you know that's the that's the fear for
me so
yeah
it would be it would be yeah
because of everything I've said like you
can't
yeah when they make a movie they're
going to want to appeal to a broad range
of people so people who have who have
watched the original movie people who
maybe have seen a little bit of sg1 and
SGA whatever but they want to feel to
them to a large group of people and have
the story make sense
so they're gonna have to do something
that either ignores a large portion of
su of the TV series
or have something very quick which
explains things but doesn't explain it
properly and it just ends up being
shipped
that's the worry but then obviously
let's say if it then bombs
the chances of a TV show are going to be
like zero yeah because I'm like well it
didn't it didn't perform well in the
cinema why would it perform well on TV
well because you made a movie about it
you didn't continue the series that's
why that's why it was [__]
so what if they met him in the middle
because tour Hudson in the comments
section just had a good idea of
why what if they did like a two-hour a
two-hour episode for the first episode
and then dive into the series they could
Star Wars the Clone Wars whenever it was
released as a series released a film
called Star Wars the Clone Wars that was
was literally the first three episodes
it was just the first Arc of the TV
series placed into it I guess that is a
little different because they released
it strictly as a film but you could
release this as a very low budget film
like a two-hour episode has maybe if
it's a 10 million dollar budget for a TV
episode for about an hour make it 20.
and then you got a two hour film that
isn't some crazy thing but you can put
it in theaters and then have it as part
of the series as well to kind of bridge
that Gap maybe I don't know save Amazon
a couple bucks
I thought I mean if if we at the moment
this I I said in the last video it's a
very my the people I speak to are
telling me it's very very unlikely the
Bad Robot are going to get this for the
reasons I've talked about and the um
Sidetrack sides video
um which we can go on which I can repeat
if if people want me to but
um so I mean times very unlikely but
it's still possible this is still in the
mix all right
if we hopefully
that the negotiations between MGM and
penguin in the park get crack on and
they make the TV show
My worry is that they're in no rush to
get the TV show sorted because they're
going to make a movie first so in which
case they actually don't need to worry
about it sort of thing but anyway
do we want
bad robots do a movie and then Pig in
penguin in a Parker to develop the
series
for me that's the that's the worst thing
they could do
it's just because then you've got a
problem with Canon because you've got
two things going on
yeah so bad robot will have their ideas
or what's what should happen in a movie
but obviously
uh Fergus and otsbury they've they've
they've developed they've got their
their Bible then they know how a series
should continue
yeah
um it's going to be disjointed isn't it
yeah yeah
well it would work fine if they had a
Kevin feige or if they had Brad right
back honestly uh not just to toss his
name up in there again but he would be a
great fightiest guy even if he's not
completely and utterly in charge to to
guide the path of the overarching story
of both
yeah if they went down more of a Marvel
style
how they do their movies and TV shows
where they do actually interconnect and
everything that's happened in the TV
shows happened in the movies and vice
versa
that's that'll be better
but how do you how do you write a
Stargate movie that again honors
everything that's happened before and
lets casual viewers understand what's
going on
I think you can do a standalone movie
that
that that is just because it's a big
enough Universe they can just do a story
that doesn't talk about
everything else so don't talk about
bc306s don't talk about the Jaffa don't
talk about whatever just do a very
focused story
that still has the star getting it and
still going
um an SG team on a world bad guy blah
blah blah craziness happens
I just don't think it'll appease Gators
I think Gators will be upset I think
this way the Star Trek movies that JJ
Abrams did
I've said this a million times they're
good films they're entertaining movies
but they're not Star Trek
they're Star Trek by name only
is there a risk that if I've robot do
this and they have to go that way
that it has to be to sort of standalone
and or even if they do it hand in hand
with penguin in the Parker it's still
gonna have to be Standalone that it will
be a good entertaining movie just not
Stargate
standalone
maybe but still just
like like you said the Jafar why
couldn't we have a Jafar movie can we
just have a teoc movie and screw all
trying to figure out if RDA or Kurt
Russell's coming back just just give
Tioga movie have him doing something
leading the Jafar now
I mean why not he
uh Chris judge is a big star right now
get him to a little God of War get him
to do a little this and
promote promo and you're all set but
be cheaper and yes there's a lot of
different angles they could take which
would be fun but are they going to get
that base reinvigorated I guess
um
one not two yeah why not do a Japanese
as well I I was I would argue that
sci-fi is on a bit of a decline at the
moment and they there aren't any big
sci-fi shows seeming to be being made at
the moment
um Star Wars and Star Treks to them I
mean new sci-fi shows it seems stranger
things
um fantasy seems to be if you look at
what's being greenlit for next year and
the next couple of years it seems to be
fantasy you could almost set a Jaffa
movie up like a fantasy movie
it's like it's a fantasy film honestly
it's not sci-fi it's fantasy go okay all
right and we see teal go off on a you
know
you know Quest sort of thing
or sailing space and going off doing
some cool Voyage or something yeah
anyway I like that though I know they've
got the staff weapons but they're more
like Klingons
they're more like you know swords and
things I don't know that's just an idea
of top of my head but
um
people
I don't know we're going back to you you
mentioned uh track movies
um so so the movies that Jay that that
that's the Kelvin timeline isn't it yeah
yeah
and they're very separate so we'll say
Discovery Picard
and everything that's already happened
now it's gonna get blurred no the lines
have become a bit blurred mate to be
honest see the way I would the way I
would have accepted it would have been
if that was if they released a movie and
it was similar to the coven timeline
entertaining movies as you said but then
the series came along and it wasn't
really collected because it was like an
alternate timeline story kind of thing
that'll be fine
ish I mean I would still be like well
what about this character this character
does and then we'd have to wait for an
answer when the actual series come out
but
yeah
just alternate realities get Daisy quick
I'm the first person to love Multiverse
stuff everything everywhere all at once
was my favorite film last year it's
amazing
uh
I feel like it's just such a wild
concept that people don't gravitate
towards it as much and I I feel like
that would hurt Stargate just as much
because it Star Wars has done a little
bit of that they were like no we gotta
stop Stargate I mean uh Star Trek I
guess kind of did the whole Kelvin
timeline and things like that
it doesn't have that big of a fan base
after the fact uh of course Comics does
great with Multiverse stuff but how hard
is it to actually Translate
something that we read and conceptualize
into all right let's make it a visual
medium and entertaining and hit this
this and this bullet point as well
going down the Multiverse route and it's
not working yeah that's kind of what um
DC have been going down the Multiverse
route and really leaned into it
particularly with um with the flash or
whatever over the last few years and hey
it got cool we got to see Michael Keaton
as Batman and things like that but on
the whole it's confusing as hell
um and I mean it gives the writers the
opportunity to do whatever they want
which is which is potentially the last
movie that's coming out is very much
just an alternate a multiversal story
because it's going to basically be
Flashpoint from the move from the comics
where he saved his mum from being killed
he creates Flashpoint and then realizes
he actually has to go back in time to
kill his mum or get ready
yeah I was still watching the Flasher
and they did that he tried to save it I
don't think he could I don't think he
did though Didier if I remember right
but I know you remember I remember him
yeah so the the version of The Flash
that goes back in time to save his mum
we've never met that version of The
Flash like that version of The Flash is
the original version
and then the new the new timeline now
where
basically Harrison Wells was he about
Thorne is is where we was where we
joined
um
yeah so if we had a movie then right say
they decide they're going to go
cinematic they're going to make a movie
what do we actually want to see I know
there's been loads of brilliant ideas
and I'm sorry guys I can't read the
comments and listen to these two idiots
at the same time so um or think but um I
know there's been some ideas bouncing
around what what what do you right now
you hate this idea you hate it
so what do you want
to speak it it is a verbal need
it that's the problem you've got any
possibility if I was if I was looking at
it like this is what would make what I
think would be entertaining I'd want
a compelling villain maybe for someone
from the past Like a Villain that maybe
hasn't that hasn't had his end the Loose
Ends or wrapped up maybe that could
return
um not vile
yeah oh did you say raw raw yeah not raw
because he's dead
um
I don't know I'd want a new bits
Anubis could come back he's not
technically dead he's not he's just In
Perpetual fighting with Omar desala but
who's to say he didn't like get the
upper hand at some point he could return
and that could be an interesting story
then we could have some epic Space
Battles we know with how CGI is now like
the but the battles we had in space on
sg1 to begin with were always really
good I really like them but they can be
so much better
how about
it's not Anubis doesn't necessarily
return but the movie is about his
followers trying
to free him to get him to allow him to
return
so the whole point is to stop the
followers from doing whatever it is
they're going to do to
let you know what they're all trying to
ascend so they can go and fight Omar
what where did you go to that no there
could be a million ways they could bring
he's ascended the only way that his
followers would be able to interact with
him or the person battling him would be
for them to ascend they're building an
Anubis magnet and when they turn it on
it'll just suck his energy being to the
magnet
or something I don't know they'll find
there'll be some ancient weapon or
something that they go and find that
allows them to kill Omer so that he can
return or something like that the weapon
from the Ark of Truth gets activated it
kills all the ascended beings but
somehow doesn't kill Anubis and then he
comes back
there you go see we got there in the end
and nobody has to stand but again yeah
why not
the only thing that worries me with that
is
if you can't go Multiverse immediately
because it's it's too kind of tiny whimy
mumbo jumbo for people to kind of
comprehend especially off the bat is is
ascendancy the best thing to start with
that's my only hesitation there because
I love that idea but
something like it would be really easy
to explain in the movie you just say he
was the he was the worst of the worst
this guy was
a bad man and we defeated him done two
lines you've explained that to anybody
that didn't watch the series
these followers are trying to find I
didn't catch that sorry I said in
Palpatine returned and then Palpatine
turns off in his hood in a hoodie
um you know what all these kids all
these teenagers wearing hoodies and
doing like this they're just Little Star
Wars fans all those teenagers you see on
the street
I'm actually really really liking this
idea because I really want to see Anubis
like
now with like modern like effects
because it was just a man in a in a
massive like dressing gown like in the
first one
what would they even do that's I mean
that'd be they have so many different
cool ways that they could do that
hmm
but um
the guy from the uh astral Diner who
played him you know
like I couldn't say that I thought about
him in a video a couple of weeks ago and
I couldn't see his name
his name
um I'd like to see as well let's do a
film I love it when they do films when
um like say the the hero the heroes lose
so I quite like those sort of films and
I'd love it if they you know they fight
and they think and actually they fail
you know they have to do small victory
don't they have to do like so sort of
like oh are we the you save the kids or
Anubis
um is released so Anubis gets released
but we did save the kids you know that
type of thing but I quite like it when
you know the the hero fails and then
that is a great way to slide straight
into a series
because then they're looking for an Uber
and you've got a goal there's my
favorite villain so so doing do an
infinity war and then and then slide
into a TV series and close it off yeah
why not I can start at the end a little
bit well you're not starting the end
because we've already battled Anubis
loads of times and then you bring in the
evil Ewoks at some point the feelings
come on we've sort this out for him but
the amount of times we've sort this out
for [__] Amazon if Anubis like
because Anubis was super powerful and we
kind of we got lucky with defeating
Anubis we didn't actually do anything it
was over to Silo we got really lucky if
he came back I could imagine they'd be
like yeah well we defeated you once
before and then they would like
get really cocky about it
and then he'd actually come down and be
like
nah I just wipe [__] like just kill
everyone
actually I'd quite enjoy that
if we don't get that I want the space
fantasy Adventure movie with Jafar they
fight the furlings and then Eris bot
comes back because Sam Jones is still
alive we might as well use them
why not and then I don't know then raw
turns up here all of the above we've got
a Trilogy for you and then an Anubis
just like
wipes him out
again
and then a positive I'm Not Dead
no you've died again
no because then if they do that they'd
have to do a really bad CGI Cliff Simon
and I don't want to see that no no no no
no no no that would be awful
um
right
so if if you think of it from like the
executive's point of view then what do
you actually think we're going to get if
they do a movie first
I genuinely think we're gonna get
something along the lines of this I
don't think we'll get something that
talks a lot about series I think it's
going to be way more linked to the movie
and I hope they just do something really
really simple because
um if they over complicate this it's
going to be a [__] cluster [__] it's
just it'll just be a nightmare if they
overdo this if they're going to do a
cinematic movie which I hope they don't
but if they do I just want a nice simple
action movie something that people like
and then we can boom straight into the
series that will actually enjoy the
Gators will actually enjoy
um
I think though they will that's what
they'll do they'll do something along
the lines of this this pitch
it'll be something like that that we we
end up getting to see
what do you think
I could see it I just I don't want a
formulaic generic just basic little
action movie I I want something like
that but just not I don't I don't want
the exact carbon copy of the film just
updated with better graphics and stuff I
mean
this all started with the old Roland
numerick back in in the 90s you know and
and Independence Day was right after and
then just look how that sequel turned
out I I that's what I would worry that
they're gonna try to just
because that's that's a simple good
little action movie I don't know good it
might be a little bit of a
big word to put there but uh
that worries me just as much as it could
be exciting
um
I want a spectacle sorry I want yeah I
wanna I wanna two-hour advert for the
um you know for the new series Stargate
is back I want a popcorn movie and and
this is me because I like to go to the
cinema I like to turn my brain off and I
like to go oh that blew up lovely and
that's when I that's what I enjoy the
cinema
um if I want a serious move that I want
to actually have to think about
um then you know I watch out at home I
don't really go to the cinema to watch
that you don't feel like I said there's
no difference I can watch it on my TV at
home and they'll have just as much of an
impact to the cinema though a big movie
is cool
uh big sounds I want my eardrums to go
is it as [__] blows up
um
and that that'd be cool but I wanted I
want a 90 minute two hour exciting
advert for what's coming next I just
think it's really really risky
they could bring it they could do it and
uh introduce a new villain
yeah like
they could mention oh 30 years ago we
went through the gates of aberdos and we
met the go out and then we did all this
this crazy stuff now we've got this new
villain and that kind that that would
respect the TV show
whilst pushing it Forward I think
streaming services nowadays though do we
need a movie
I would argue that um the special
effects and stuff we're getting in some
of these streams are well-funded
streaming service
of 10 episodes 10 hours 7 or 8 million
dollars an episode
you know
is is near Cinema quality
right so
well here's a question for you then
before we answer that if we get a TV
series do you think we'll ever get a
movie
oh yeah
TV series first
possibly
I don't think it would be on the ground
spectacle as if you did it first it
would be more
probably more of like an up up a higher
budget kind of like Arc of Truth
Continuum like they were direct to DVD
but obviously DVDs Out DVD doesn't exist
anymore like it'll be a
like a special episode kind of thing
that's what I think they'd do it'd be
considered a movie because of the length
and and the budget they put in but it
would more really just be a a special
episode I mean though a straight to
cinema moving a cinematic movie I mean
Prime can do a movie Prime can do a
double episode and set it up like a
movie anytime at once
because they could have done that with
the original Stargate series but they
three I think one of part of the reasons
why they didn't is because
because of everything that happened
before they couldn't just put a movie
out to the cinema because no one didn't
understand it and I think if they do TV
series first and then make a movie it it
basically do the same sort of thing yeah
what do you think Harris like I say a
cinematic movie if they do a TV series
first will we ever get cinematic release
possibly I I'd like to say probably not
in that big old spectacle kind of format
but
why not it kind of seems like
I mean you know I got my kyber crystal
right next to my Stargate right here so
I I kind of keep bringing back Star Wars
into the fold but the Clone Wars did do
that kind of double triple episode to
start off a series and did release it
cinematically and then it wasn't all
that much of a spectacle but it did set
up the reins for the series just to go
on and and do well uh
uh now we we don't know for sure but of
course all these different shows that
are coming on Mandalorian Ahsoka book of
Boba Fett all these different spin-offs
coming it's seemingly so at least that
they're working up towards a film to put
all the villains in and thrawn's gonna
be kind of like their their Thanos in a
way
I don't see why Stargate couldn't do
something like that if but then then it
gets a little dicey because are you
gonna have one series or are you gonna
start a bunch of spin-offs again which
very well may lower the viewing rates of
all the series together uh and kind of
they all have their own niches kind of
deal yeah uh it could go either way
you'd hope that I don't know I kind of
feel like working up to a big spectacle
movie would be better
but if you want to just get ashes and
seats and then get people to view the
series right after a big spectacle movie
starting off would probably be the more
producer executive oriented thing to do
yeah so now I've heard this rumor about
a cinematic release a couple of times
that Stargate would be considered and
and the main reason I keep being told it
um is because Stargate is mgm's 10th
highest gross movie of all time they
made a crap load of money on that movie
um and I get that but it was also 30
years ago
so I think they also didn't make it well
yeah they didn't make it it was
Lionsgate wasn't it I think and they
sold it landscape thought we're not
going to make any money on this let's
sell it and MGM went we'll give you 15
million quid it then went on to take 150
million quit so it did very well
um
the the thing that I would argue is if
they go with the TV series I don't think
Stargate is big enough I actually don't
think Stargate will ever be the
franchise that Star Trek is
because it's just not ingrained in
culture the way Star Trek is
so but but don't get me wrong it's my
favorite show I think it's better than
Star Trek um I wrote In A Thing on nine
Chevrons about how I think it's better
than Star Trek
um but I don't think it'll ever be as
popular I don't think they'll be far off
but not quite as popular
I don't I don't see a cinema I don't see
the need to do a cinematic release what
they should do is do a series if they
want to put an MGM plus put it on MGM
Plus
um I'll pay five pound a month to watch
Stargate I don't you know I'll I'll I'll
do that I don't want to but I will and
then if you want to then do a movie put
it on Prime
they make enough other movies go
straight to Prime
yeah they did borax straight to Prime
that did quite well
let's go straight to Prime
um so do that don't do a cinematic movie
it's I think this is only I think this
rumor started about cinematic movie
because Amazon want to do four or five
cinema movies a year and they're trying
to figure out what to do and some bright
spark has gone why don't we do Stargate
and then we can kick off and that's I
think generally what slowed everything
down
I think we would have had the
announcement months ago except they're
seriously thinking about this movie idea
and it slowed everything down so now
they're all like oh now we don't know
what to do
um
and I think
if they're gonna do a move you know let
penguin in a park and do it
thank you TV series we'll get a coherent
story
let's do something that then sets up a
TV series that then we'll be excited
about
I don't think there should be multiple
production companies even if they were
doing movies and TV it should be one
so you've got a cohesive story you need
you need that tangibility you need
whatever happens in the movie to have
existed in the in the in the series and
vice versa say that like like how Marvel
will do it you need you need that yeah
you need one captain of the ship I think
and if that's Mark Fergus or whoever
um I don't really care and while I do go
because that's the most important person
but I've always thought that some I
don't thought I don't really care to a
point too Fair because I think the
showrunner doesn't necessarily have to
be the creative force behind it Brad
Wright was always the creative showroom
it's almost like a bit of an
old-fashioned showrunner really Alex
kurtzman gets all the [__] for Star Trek
but actually he's not the creative force
behind any of it he's a manager
you know Kevin FEI has never been a
writer he's never been an executive
producer his name from this he's a
manager he manages
the thing you know he's like he's the
captain of the ship but he doesn't do
the steering Brad Wright was there doing
the steering doing the you know doing
the you know checking the stars for
which way they're going and you know and
he did everything
um Kevin feige thank you steers
he steers a little bit [__] steers a
little bit he's an executive producer
I
think he says no a lot I think he's like
somebody will come up with an idea and I
think he's quite good at going no with
not doing that we're going this way and
I think maybe
people forget that he was a producer on
every single Marvel film from blade to
Spider-Man all the X-Men all the way up
until he knows everything about the
comics oh God he's the biggest nerd and
thing but I think he's a manager I think
he's in charge in the right direction
I don't think he's coming up with new
ideas but I think he's really brilliant
at saying what's a bad idea
and or only rain it also is really good
at raining it in if he's a guy
well yeah well look I think with taika
waititi
um and
um somebody was reigning taika watiti in
a Ragnarok and I always wonder if maybe
Kevin feige or or his team are there
going in on like pull back a little bit
pull back and you know that's a bit too
far but then that Ragnarok was so
popular they went okay we trust you and
we got love and thunder yeah and he went
too far you know and I wonder if Kevin
Fey's there going I remember we should
have been watching him
I mean you just made a good point
because fagi was in charge of all that
and what's kind of the Reigns and then
phase four happened and he did take a
step back and I should know the two
producers names off of the dot my head
but he has a lady and a guy that are
like his second in commands really and
they they were in charge of phase four
and
it's all going to pop Yeah well yeah so
we we 100 need
somebody in charge we just don't want
that to be JJ Abrams yeah we need
guidance we just don't need the the
guidance of a battery boost but it's
anyway I I don't think the main reason
why I honestly don't think though that
MGM are going to go this way or Amazon
are going to go this way is because I
honestly think Bad Robot are about to
get sued by Warner Brothers
for a lot of money
and I I think it'll I mean like I say
that there were four years into this
five-year deal that they've got with
Warner Brothers and they've produced
nothing
and everything that they did have lined
up that they had a Superman movie lined
up that ain't happening they had two
Batman cartoons happening James Gunn
hasn't mentioned him when he talked
about the everything that's being done
so it doesn't look like they're
happening
um
I've heard rumor this week that they
were doing a Speed Racer TV series and
apparently Apple aren't happy with it so
that might not be happening so they're
going to get to the end of four years
into a five-year deal and they've
produced nothing
and Warner Brothers at some point might
just go you've breached your contract
you know you we gave you 250 million
dollars to produce TV and movie content
and you've done nothing
but also everything they've pitched
Warner Brothers gone that's crap an
Amazon aren't stupid they've got to be
watching that and go in they've just
lost this is a this isn't a new up and
coming production company this is a
production company that has had a deal
with Warner Brothers and has done
nothing and wasted five years and 250
million dollars and I'm telling you what
right now Amazon do not want to waste
money
the last thing they want to do is waste
so I I don't think it'll happen
um and I only think JJ Abrams would get
involved in a movie I can understand why
bad Royal bought a pitching for this
because they're desperately looking for
other work this is why they pitched that
Star Trek 4 movie and leaked it
that they were going to make Star Trek
four
um and you know it was leaked because
none of the actors knew
um so they leaked it trying to get a bit
of momentum going
and then basically the Warner Brothers
went you can't you've got an exclusivity
deal with us
empowerment when you can't we don't want
to
and so all of a sudden quietly went away
but I think it was um I think they
thought the fans were going to go crazy
well it mounts it fans will go crazy and
then we'll get to make the film and
we'll get out of the Warner Brothers
contract and we'll get to make the film
and then maybe we'll get to make
Stargate and it just blew up in their
faces
[Music]
uh
I I don't think we need a movie I think
a TV series and then a straight to
Amazon Prime is more
much safer
than I think much better yeah
yeah
something the fans will appreciate more
yeah I'm back into it yeah more logical
more likely
as well
so yeah so that's where we're at really
so the Bad Robot thing look we share it
because I got I learned about it and it
scared us all to death but I don't think
it's gonna happen anyway
hopefully not on the keeping mat up
he's much sleepy
I am I'm actually I'm quite tired yeah
it's 10 a.m what are you talking about
that's not 10 a.m here
I've got work tomorrow oh
bloody hell it's anyway before we close
up for the day
um and guys get in the comments there's
anything else you wanted to mention
we'll just run our normal uh promos
again
one second here are the adverts nine
chevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to new
stories that we break check out some of
the news articles that we have already
at nineshavrons.com
Sidetrack also has some amazing merch
get yours today and show your support at
side-track.com
guys if you got any comments or any
questions you got before we head off
um then that would be great um let's
just have a quick look guys if you've
got anything you wanted to bring up
before we just before we disappear
I'm just scanning here I can think of
the Stargate animated idea do we like
that idea about doing a sort of a lower
decks type of series lower decks push
what if I referenced like three or four
times already give a Stargate the Clone
Wars I'm ready
I thought you're gonna say Futurama
let's do a future
absolutely just trying to think of a
Futurama joke like 20 seconds ago I
couldn't think of once I was like okay
stay quiet for a second
um yeah I I think I think so
um
uh Ambrose has been on today
um if we haven't had an announcement by
I'm gonna say April now May 1st if we
haven't had something announced by May
1st
I think we won't get Stargate until
four or five years down the line
I think he'll be I don't think he'll be
far off
and then reboot it'll be a hard reboot
well at that point would Amazon still
own the rates uh of course they're on
MGM but does did the rates for the I
guess IP kind of lapse at that point MGM
own Stargate rights they they just they
own it flat I think it'd be like 99
years
oh wow yeah as far as I know there's no
it's not because it wasn't a
distribution deal they bought
the the deal they bought it so but yeah
I I think he's probably not a Million
Miles Away there I I honestly I did a
video a little while ago then I couldn't
Stargate now or never and it's not never
I think Stargate will come back at some
point it's too big I think it was
streaming number one on Twitter again
this week trending number one in the US
and Canada
um
but
I think I think if it doesn't happen now
it will be a hard reboot because too too
long will have gone by at that point it
would have to the original cast is too
old the the whole sg1 cast is almost too
old at that point not not really
we're getting a soft reboot anyway mate
I don't think we'll get many of the cast
come back anyway we might get some
cameos we might get one back but the
only way to logically have the old cast
come back would be in senior roles like
general or yeah like advisors or things
like that anyway
yeah so I mean that that's the only way
it's going to come back I mean by the
top and congrat Michael Shanks could
come back there they're still young
enough and Ben Bowden could come back
teal could come back no bother you know
they're a lot of these actors RDA is not
going to come back in the main role and
he's he's old he's mid 70s so I mean
um but it's going to be a soft reboot
anyway it's just whether they do
the more time goes by the more likely
he's gonna be it's going to be harder
you do
and that's just the truth
sad but it's the truth it is that you
know the sleeping Giants are sci-fi
it'll happen at some point
s
so I guess we have just talked about sg1
but SGA was pretty popular also could
could they come back and do it Momoa
Ronin movie with a couple other people
of course I haven't finished SGA so I
don't know exactly what happens per se
but uh
I've said it before
Jason Ronan before he joined Atlantis
would be a really interesting story like
him as a runner would be a fantastic
story
you'd leave them you see him leave
what's his product or is it satida or
something like that you see him leave
the planet because it's a war
and then you'd see him running because
he's got he's got the tracker in his
back and how that
like plays out and then
maybe you'd see him like you'd see a
glimpse of oh now they're gonna go into
SGA
I like that it'd be fun the only thing
is Jason Moe was twice the size he
wasn't then
wow
he'd want to do it though he seems to be
still quite good friends with people
from Atlantis he he mentions it quite a
lot in interviews and things
um you know it's I I think they could I
think they could get him to do a
cinematic movie and people would watch
it I should be fair that would be a
brilliant way of getting back into
Stargate because people would go and
watch a Jason Momoa movie
and then they're like oh it's a Stargate
film and that this the fact that it's
Stargate would be secondary
it's not like it's not Stargate Ronin or
Stargate like you just call it yeah like
how how X-Men did with uh Logan
um
yeah
so yeah I think that'd be it's like a
back door reboot
yeah I mean that might honestly be like
a
a nice the bridge of the Gap I've said
it before uh already to this hour but it
bridged the gap between a lot and
he's big enough I mean and obviously
with all the DC stuff going on he's
going to get Aquaman to Aquaman made 1.2
billion dollars mostly on him alone and
then Aquaman 2 I don't think it'll make
that much but it should probably make
five six seven eight hundred million
dollars nothing to scoff at by any means
and uh
they James Gunn did say well we're
leaving the door open for Aquaman 3 to
finish the trilogy but that's just I I
hope he doesn't do that because that's
just gonna piss off so many different
people because that it makes it
confusing at that point what is it a
soft reboot is it not is it is it a hard
reboot with some soft reboot aspects to
it those questions are already there and
that would middle those questions out
even more so give them Aquaman too and
if he really wants to make another
Atlantis base something
we got Stargate why not yeah yeah it'll
be 10 years until we get Aquaman three
anyway with everything they've announced
if they do not comma three is going to
be a million miles away and I don't
think they will it took them
yeah well that's he's talking about
bringing the franchise together the DC's
franchise together and getting it to
make sense
if you're going to do that you've kind
of got to cut off at some point and I
know they're bringing the Flash and
we've got Blue Beetle which is which is
a new character that's fine an Aquaman
too you know but then after that
bringing in one bringing Wonder Woman
back how could oh no we're gonna have to
have a new Batman again another new
Batman
um another new Superman now it's I can't
I can't see them
well I suppose they're cherry picking
the bits they like from the Snyder verse
and ignoring the bits they don't and
that's just gonna piss people off
it's gonna be interesting yeah 100 right
guys thank you so much we've had a
brilliant conversation as always and
thanks everybody in the comments you've
you've kept us going as always
um I've got back through and read them
all because I saw some really good story
ideas and I've just you know you see
somebody calling you around I'm like I
can't read that because it'll I'll get
I'll lose my train of thought but um but
I'll go back and read them now uh next
week we are doing the um top five Sci-Fi
movies of all time and it's Gotta Be
proper Sci-Fi movies none of this so
none of this like oh it's a horror movie
really Sci-Fi movies all right so top
five of all time
good luck with that I've already had a
hell of a time
um and I've I wrote down Spaceballs
every single time and they went damn it
it's a comedy they don't have one
Spaceballs is primarily a comedy
yeah damn it so
um I think we're gonna have some
arguments but and we'll hopefully
hopefully fingers crossed stormy will be
back but he's working hard with him at
the moment building spaceships
so let's see what happens he's the true
sci-fi guy oh yes I mean he'll come up
with some great but we'll get his
selections anyway but guys once again
thank you so so much we will see you
next week
um
everybody bye now
say bye yeah
[Music]